la anemia falciforme es una enfermedad
sanguínea hereditaria que afecta a los
glóbulos rojos es una de las formas más
comunes y por lo general más graves de
un grupo de trastornos de los glóbulos
rojos denominado enfermedades células
falciformes para sobrevivir su cuerpo
necesita glóbulos rojos para suministrar
oxígeno a sus tejidos
los glóbulos rojos se producen en el
interior de los huesos en la llamada
médula ósea allí las células inmaduras
llamadas células madre de la sangre
pueden dividirse para producir todos los
tipos de células sanguíneas incluidos
los glóbulos rojos los glóbulos rojos
normales tienen forma de disco cada uno
de ellos contiene moléculas de proteína
conocidas como hemoglobina que
transportan oxígeno los glóbulos rojos
redondos y flexibles circulan fácilmente
por el torrente sanguíneo y recogen el
oxígeno en los pulmones
en los diminutos sacos de aire de los
pulmones llamados alvéolos el oxígeno
pasa la sangre y se une a la hemoglobina
de los glóbulos rojos
a continuación los glóbulos rojos llevan
el oxígeno a las células de todo el
cuerpo en la anemia falciforme Hay un
problema con la hemoglobina que hace que
los glóbulos rojos tengan forma de Oz en
lugar de ser redondos la causa es un gen
defectuoso que se transmite de ambos
padres a los hijos a través del material
genético de sus células conocido como
ADN el ADN está formado por unas
secciones que se llaman genes dos de los
genes alfaglobina y betaglobina
contienen los planos para fabricar las
proteínas de la hemoglobina
en la anemia falciforme el gen de la
betaglobina ha cambiado o ha mutado
esta mutación causa la formación de una
proteína de hemoglobina anormal conocida
como hemoglobina s
la hemoglobina s se forma en hebras
rígidas dentro de los glóbulos rojos lo
que hace que el glóbulo rojo tenga forma
de Oz
las células falciformes pueden bloquear
el flujo sanguíneo y causar dolor y
daños en los tejidos y mientras que los
glóbulos rojos normales duran entre 90 y
120 días los falsiformes solo duran
Entre 10 y 20 días
es posible que su cuerpo no pueda
mantener el ritmo debido a la rapidez
con la que se destruyen las células y
como resultado su sangre tendrá menos
glóbulos rojos de lo normal
esta afección se llama anemia los
síntomas de la anemia falciforme varían
de una persona a otra pero pueden
incluir episodios de dolor en partes del
cuerpo
como las manos y los pies la parte baja
de la espalda el pecho y el abdomen un
tinte amarillo en el blanco de los ojos
y en la piel llamado ictericia y
sensación de cansancio debido a la
anemia
con el tiempo la anemia falciforme puede
provocar complicaciones como dolor
intenso y daños en los ojos el corazón
los pulmones el hígado los riñones y las
articulaciones los daños en el vaso un
órgano que produce células inmunitarias
pueden aumentar el riesgo de infecciones
el riesgo de padecer anemia falciforme
es mayor entre las personas con
ancestros procedentes del África
subsahariana y de zonas hispanas de
Sudamérica El Caribe y América Central
Arabia Saudita
India y los países mediterráneos
para saber más sobre la anemia
falciforme hable con su proveedor de
atención médica